you obviously don't take this job very
seriously sir it's just these particular
marbles I just needed to feel what they
felt like in my mouth I don't know what
is wrong with me you know we do serious
business here right yes I do know that
I'm 100 aware of that yeah because I've
forgotten where I was you were saying
the justice is a dumb blind old lady I
heard everything yes no she's not dumb
but she is blind
she's reminiscent of uh Kerry Washington
[Music]
okay all right good morning Tom Jason
how you doing there Dave Crystal Tommy
good morning Jake how are ya
pretty good Kenny yeah yeah I you know
so early in the morning I'm sorry to be
very bad news but uh you know how I was
supposed to work late tonight well I
gotta run this errand for Mr mahina and
he says that you're gonna have to cover
for me so there it is I don't need I'm
sorry drop the ax okay so hmm
again yeah
oh you know what just remembered Mr
mahina also almost slipped my mind wants
us to change parking spaces what yeah me
personally I enjoy the nine minute walk
but uh he said that we have to do it
believe it I hate it as much as you do
what are you gonna do nothing you can do
Mr mahina said it mahina this whole
situation has been mayanized it just
seems a little confusing to me as to why
Mr mahina would give a where we
park
how's that I mean why would he care
where we park I I don't know the answer
to that question I mean that's it's just
what he said hey the mahina works in
mysterious ways you know what I'm gonna
ask him myself because no that's okay
I'll do it
uh Mr mahina sir I know you're busy but
can I speak to you about the parking
switch what is there to talk about Kenny
I told you and Jake to switch parking
Springfield know who I am I am Mr mahina
and I'm a real real person in here
[Music]
wow I'm sure that it was crazy in there
I mean that was
tense yeah you know what's really crazy
though I've been working here for about
a year and I've never even seen Mr
mahina well see now that's that's an
easy one to answer that's because he
comes in before you come into work and
he's still working when you leave that's
what makes a Mr mahina you know come on
we're talking about Mr Vegeta here right
it makes perfect sense you know I bet
the hard-working boss would love to meet
a hard-working employee you know shares
the same values so I'm gonna go ahead
and just introduce myself no no uh you
can't go into Mr behind his room are you
crazy no one except me is allowed to go
in there Mr mahina is busy
okay fine you made your point clear man
thank you very much Jake I think
come on man
what
question my existence will you
oh
the end of the year report to you by 10.
Marjorie I'd love a cupcake
thank you so much for coming today uh as
you know every year the vice president
hosts the annual company luncheon so I
brought you here to make sure that none
of my material could be in any way
misconstrued as sexist or racist or
homophobic so if you hear anything that
could be in any way offensive to anyone
just raise your hand and oh I haven't
really started yet did you find
something offensive the fact that you
think I need a man's permission to raise
my hand is insane I can raise my hand
whenever I want to raise my hand because
I'm a free woman so I should just raise
my hand like this like a big old black
power fist yeah huh boss man is that
what you want from me is this what you
wanted a floppy gay hand just floating
around in the air well here you go
here's my floppy gay hand at the end of
my limp gay wrist happy no Jesus no wow
what why not marry no or Rachel no or
Bathsheba know why does it have to be
Jesus a man and are we talking about the
Jesus that accepts everyone or the Jesus
who doesn't believe that people should
be able to love who they love oh maybe I
should just break out in some gospel
song screaming and hollering and hooting
oh Lord
no this isn't the speech yet can I just
do the speech oh you want this to
shut up is that it what's the matter the
black guys making way too much noise in
your movie theater forgive me for
listening and lilting through your
speech no I just meant
with the hands man I ain't gonna shoot
you what are you gonna grab my breath
now protect yourself from the gay
Invasion guys
eyes
should I leave sorry men and women let's
exclude everybody who identifies
themselves as something else because
they're not people I meant people whose
people my people do I speak for my
people all right more like all white
more like no rights more like women or
second-class citizens right okay stop
men women people of all ethnicities
genders sexual orientation religion can
I please just get to my speech
fine yeah
um
okay here goes
a pollock and an Arab walk into
a bar I love Arab jokes ching chong
bring it on you had me a Pollock
Noah Sanders here for the job interview
please take a seat
[Music]
[Applause]
job interviews huh
never fun
okay
I get it stay focused
[Music]
oh
that's a big laugh
foreign
[Laughter]
thanks so much for coming in Adam of
course and you better stay away from
that Chinese oh my God you got that
right I've done a number on my stomach
come on
[Laughter]
oh my gosh what an absolute Delight it's
been great and can I tell you something
yeah
I don't even care if I get this job
because I know I've made a friend for
life
terrific attitude
attitude damn attitude yeah you son of a
gun
you know what
right quick before you leave I want to
give you something no sir I can't take
any more gifts this whole thing has been
a gift
my brother passed away
21 years ago
we were estranged and he became ill
and he gave this to me as a peace
offering
and then one day when we were on the
ocean he fell overboard on about very
much like this one and died
I saw him struggling all the way as a
Riptide just pulled
except this is a as a token of my
gratitude for you bringing Joy back into
my life
under any other circumstance I would
refuse
[Music]
accept this gift today
thank you
oh he made it
[Laughter]
[Music]
this guy how do you keep a straight face
all day
and she's sweet it's weird oh my God God
damn it I love your energy well
what can I say sir I am solar powered
really you like you like that one huh
I've never been a part of it my entire
life
okay who's next
you ready let's go chop chop here we go
come on let's go
okay
[Music]
requesting permission to come on board
sir hi Noah Sanders name uh sorry to
hear about your brother maybe we can get
some Chinese food after this all right
all right okay take it easy
I don't know
[Music]
turbo welcome to the team Mr wise thank
you now being an Arizona assistant
State's Attorney is an important job one
we take very seriously in fact we are
willing to do anything to win it's my
honor sir and I look forward to serving
the State of Arizona are these marbles
how's that
it's just admiring your container of
marbles
why yes
my wife got them for me as a gift
for my birthday
which brings me to a speech where I like
to give anyone on their first day here
at the state's attorney office of
Arizona
you see
Lady Justice is a committed woman she's
a slippery little scallop as you can
observe
[Music]
[Applause]
what is going on
what what are you doing
oh uh
marbles they're just I I gotta tell you
they're just so beautiful that I was
wondering what it would feel like in my
mouth like what would the marbles feel
like if they were in my mouth
yes you know
what
just you know you know like this what
would it feel like if they were just
kind of a whole ton of marbles in my in
my face
well don't do that
just
just don't do that yeah yeah of course
of course
why why what am I doing over here I mean
that's that's the thing that a child
would do you know you were saying
I was saying that lady Justice just
stands there in my office
looking at me
[Music]
[Applause]
forget the marbles boy
spit the marbles out please
there you go
well
all right
ah
how many
really
do you have any
I'm gonna wait for the last
I'm assuming this yeah
I know there's another one in there
yep all right
I am I'm they're just so beautiful I
can't it's just these marbles I gotta
tell you you obviously don't take this
job here seriously sir it's just these
particular marbles I just needed to feel
what they felt like in my mouth I don't
know what is wrong with me no we do
serious business here right yes I do
know that I'm 100 aware of that yeah
because I've forgotten where I was you
were saying that Justice is a dumb blind
old lady I heard everything yes no she's
not dumb
but she's blind
she's reminiscent of a Kerry Washington
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
send in the cleanup crew
another one fell for the marble trick
[Music]
but I don't know me